overwatch has 21 radically different
characters but blizzard isn't stopping
there we've now gotten a look at the
game's first new playable character and
the rumors were mostly true Farrah's
mother Anna is a healing sniper who fits
perfectly into the support category
sounds like being an awesome soldier
runs in the family so what gadgets does
onna have at her disposal her biotic
rifle can heal teammates of course but
it will also deal ongoing damage to your
opponent's her biotic grenade also heals
friends while damaging foes but on top
of that it boosts overall healing for
your team and prevents enemies from
healing at all her other gadget is a
sleep dart which should come in handy if
you need to quickly drop an opponent to
the ground then there's her ultimate
which basically turns teammates into
super soldiers with faster movement
higher attack damage and higher damage
resistance Farrah's mom doesn't mess
around starting today PC players can try
out on a through blizzards public test
realm there's no current word on her
full release or when she'll come to
consoles you can expect plenty more
characters and balance changes down the
road but if you want to keep up with all
the overwatch news you're already in the
right place
I